bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo en compagnie
cette semaine de delphine girard bonjour
45 minutes à passer ensemble pour passer
en revue l'actualité politique et
parlementaire avec cette semaine
l'arrivée à l'assemblée du collectif
budgétaire 2012 en vedette la
suppression de la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires qui était l'une
des mesures phare de nicolas sarkozy
l'opposition évidemment est monté au
créneau
rénover la vie publique c'est la mission
qu'a confié françois hollande à lionel
jospin avec un rapport attendu début
novembre
l'ancien premier ministre devra plancher
sur le cumul des mandats ou encore la
réforme du statut pénal du chef de
l'état dans sa commission une ancienne
ministre ump roselyne bachelot enfin le
parti socialiste prépare son congrès de
l'automne et l'élection de son nouveau
chef
cette semaine c'était le ramassage des
copies des contributions tous en rang ou
presque derrière le texte de martine
aubry et jean-marc ayrault
il y a bien sûr quelques indisciplinés
qui ont déposé leurs propres textes
comme le ministre benoît hamon ou encore
comme vous marie noëlle lienemann
bonjour bonjour jean ministre sénatrice
socialiste de paris
alors vous représenter l'ailé gauche du
parti vous êtes une proche de benoît
hamon vous avez d'ailleurs signé sa
contribution il y en a et vous avez
également apporter votre propre
contribution
vous l'avez vous même qualifié d' un peu
raide pour l'europe parce qu'elle a
rencontré un succès cette contribution
on a plusieurs députés parlementaires on
essaie cette parlementaire on a des
premiers secrétaires du parti socialiste
on a aussi des des responsables des
secrétaires nationaux puisque les quatre
premiers signataires sont jérôme guedj
qui est le présent causé général de
l'essonne et nous avons emmanuel maurin
et marianne louis secrétaire nationale
et moi même mais on a aussi des
ministres plus chevronnés comme paul
quilès gens au cou
jean le garrec donc vous avez le mélange
des générations n'a pas tous la même
histoire mais on est tous convaincus
qu'aujourd'hui se joue beaucoup de la
réussite de ce quinquennat
la sortie de crise de ce pays et que
c'est à travers une réorientation réelle
et pas formelle de l'union européenne
que
que nous devons passer mais aussi par
des choix qui par exemple ramène l'état
le capital public dans l'économie parce
qu'on réindustrialiser sera pas la
france et notamment avec sa mutation
technologique écologique sans cet
investissement public lourd en irak les
régions nous pensons aussi que la
question des salaires n'est pas un
handicap à la con à la productivité et à
la compétitivité
bref nous pensons qu'on peut réussir à
gauche on va en certains pensent qu'on
va reparler de tout ça mais certains
pensent quand même beaucoup que la
réussite du quinquennat dont vous parlez
passe par la discipline du parti
c'était en tout cas un peu le message
qu'ont fait passer il s'agit pas d'être
indiscipliné
il ya un congrès si c'était un congrès
ça sert à quoi ça sert à à débattre moi
je suis quand même très très étonné
d'abord on a l'expérience on sait que si
on n'est pas capable au début du qe2 du
quinquennat d'avoir les vrais débats qui
traversent la société française
notamment l'électorat de gauche
si on n'est pas capable d'être en écoute
avec ces populations avec ses attentes
et de la facture se paye au moment de
l'élection dans cinq ans et on ne peut
pas faire comme si la question de 2002
est définitivement derrière nous donc le
débat que veut françois hollande avec
les partenaires sociaux pour vous l'ayez
aussi en interne
oui et puis alors qu'il ya des choses
tout à fait drôle que j'apprécie
beaucoup dans la contribution du marc
ayrault et de martine aubry dont chacun
a bien vu qu'il souhaitait je ne veux
voir qu'une seule tête il est écrit le
parti socialiste est un parti de débat
avec l'ensemble des forces autour de
nous le premier débat c'est avec ces
militants avec ses adhérents les
primaires n'ont pas affaibli notre
candidat le débat interne l'affaiblira
ni notre parti ni notre gouvernement
alors marie noëlle lienemann on va
dérouler ensemble fil de la semaine si
vous le voulez bien et lundi à propos de
file détricote à l'assemblée
en ce début de semaine les députés
examinent le projet de loi de finances
rectificative pour 2002 qui prévoit 7 2
milliards de recettes supplémentaires au
menu notamment l'abrogation d'une mesure
phare de l'ère sarkozy la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
désormais les salariés paieront des
impôts sur ces heures-là reste à définir
à partir de quand et là lundi ça
cafouille un peu jamie hartman a à quand
la fin des heures supplémentaires
défiscalisées
toute la journée le gouvernement et sa
majorité ont multiplié les déclarations
contraires finalement matignon souhaite
une entrée en vigueur au 1er août alors
que le rapporteur du budget à
l'assemblée le socialiste christian
eckert évoque la date du 1er juillet
mesure peut-être d' équilibre et
peut-être de nature à assurer une bonne
information pour ceux qui n'auraient pas
entendu dire pendant les campagnes
électorales que les heures
supplémentaires ne sont plus encouragés
par l'argent public
ce matin encore ce même christian eckert
proposer par voie d'amendement
la date du 1er janvier 2012 autrement
dit une application rétroactive de la
mesure qui aurait permis près d'un
milliard d'euros d'économies pour les
caisses de l'état
oui mais voilà à cette date là françois
hollande n'était pas encore président de
la république et les salariés qui
effectué des heures supplémentaires
n'étaient pas censés savoir qu'elle
serait soumise à l'impôt
devant les protestations de l'opposition
le gouvernement a donc retardé la mise
en application de sa mesure même si on
nous dit juillet c'est mieux que janvier
a ni scandale ça reste un scandale sous
la pression ils ont reculé pas assez
nous ne voulons pas qu'il y ait de
remise en cause de la défiscalisation et
rétroactivité au 1er janvier ou au 1er
juillet ça reste un scandale sans nom
car sur le fond l'objectif du
gouvernement reste lui inchangé
récupérer les 5 milliards d'euros que
coûte et chaque année depuis cinq ans
les heures supplémentaires défiscalisées
cher à nicolas sarkozy alors un coup 1er
juillet
1er janvier puis finalement premier
route vous allez dire que celle de
l'activité parlementaire qui veut ça le
débat parlementaire mais ça donne quand
même cette impression d'un cafouillage
sur un sujet qui finalement toucher au
pouvoir d'achat des foyers moi je pense
que bon c'est aussi la vie parlementaire
faut pas surestimer ce qui est quand
même important c'est finalement ce qui
est voté en même temps ça veut aussi
dire que c'est très important que le
gouvernement travailler en bonne entente
mans je ne sais pas qui je ne suis pas
l'assemblée et au sénat
j'ai personnellement je pense que ça
veut dire que quand même le gouvernement
de travailler au près serré avec les
parlementaires pour que s'il ya des
désaccords réels des choses sur lequel
on veut infléchir ce soit clair mais que
ce soit pas sur des choses qui
apparaissent finalement assez
incompréhensible pour nos concitoyens
est la rétroactivité vous la trouvez pas
injuste c'est un principe habituel qu'on
essaie de combattre un de d'éviter la
rétroactivité la gav est quand même à
notre collègue eckert avait soulevée
quand même quelque chose c'est qu'il ya
eu des des heures supplémentaires
d'opportunités nous savons par exemple
que pendant un certain nombre d'années
les heures supplémentaires ont été
substitutives à l'augmentation des
salaires parce qu'évidemment on mettait
des heures supplémentaires j'allais pas
dire fictif ce que je suis passé jean
lui faisait ou pas mais ont gonflé le
quota d'heures supplémentaires pour
éviter l'augmentation des salaires parce
que cette course était l'état finalement
qui paient cette mesure donc on a vu
aussi que dans la période du début
d'année
un certain nombre d'entreprises ont
utilisé cette méthode pour booster un
peu certains voilà donc composé de 500
mais aussi quand même servir de façon
honnête n'avait absolument rien à dire
j'étais pas lâcher tout comprendre le
souci
très franchement je pense que le 1er
août est très sérieux je pense que cette
mesure doit être expliquée y comprise et
il faut pas qu'on ait un débat sur la
périphérie du sujet le vrai sujet c'est
que ce n'était pas une bonne mesure ni
pour l'emploi ce n'était pas la vraie
mesures pour le pouvoir d'achat et
s'était par ailleurs
à des éléments qui comptent qui a accru
le déficit public alors vous connaissez
les critiques qui sont faites par
l'opposition sur cette mesure ce sont
surtout les classes moyennes et les bas
salaires qui profitait de cette
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
évidemment les députés de l'opposition
et notamment d'anciens ministres sont
montés au créneau cette semaine extraits
vous êtes devenu le parti des bobos
moi j'habite rue des martyrs rue des
martyrs je veux dire les bobos les bobos
qui ont voté pour vous cela ils sont pas
concernés par le refus mais le comique
bouger la rue des martyrs
lui il a besoin des 500 euros c'est cela
qui sont les cocus de la gauche et vous
êtes devenu le parti des bobos des
petits bourgeois est pas le parti des
ouvriers françois hollande pendant la
campagne de façon constante a toujours
promis solennellement qu'il ne
toucherait pas aux exonérations de
cotisations sociales pour les salariés
dans les entreprises de moins de 20
je le cite dans une des réponses qu'il a
fait à l'émission de rtl où il était
interrogé par un ambulancier qui lui
disait monsieur hollande je vais perdre
mes cotisations sociales avec ce que
vous prévoyez est la réponse qui a été
faite par monsieur hollande je vous le
promets monsieur je maintiendrai les
cotisations sociales sur les heures
supplémentaires pour tous les salariés
des entreprises de moins de 20 salariés
c'est un flagrant délit de mensonge
politique
oui vous faites sauter le bouclier
fiscal mais c'est pour mieux mettre un
boulet fiscal à la france qui travaille
est ce que c'est une mesure de bobo la
fin de mai a dit des choses inexactes
car justement ce qu'elle m'a tenus pour
les entreprises de moins de 20 salariés
c'est l'exonération des cotisations pour
les entreprises
parce que dans ces entreprises là créer
de l'emploi en substitut aux heures
supplémentaires est beaucoup plus
difficilement comprennent rien c'est que
dans ces entreprises de moins de 20
salariés les salariés qui ont fait des
heures supplémentaires ou l'un payer des
impôts
en revanche côté de cotisations sociales
de l'entreprise seront exonérés comme
elle était auparavant pour la raison
suivante droit mas tenu promesse
exactement ce qu'il a dit est tenu alors
pour autant il faut bien ré expliquer le
ans de cela alors quand aux bobos
laissez moi rire la grande masse des
ouvriers à travaux t pour françois
hollande en tout cas nettement plus que
pour nicolas sarkozy
et c'est eux qui bénéficié en majorité
de ces exonérations d'heures
supplémentaires vous d'accord enfin les
ouvriers ou les employés toute façon
c'était pas les gens qui sont forfait
donc il faut faire de 10 euros rapport à
des heures supplémentaires donc bon
c'est vrai que c'est plutôt le monde du
travail
intel s'est rarement les cadres
supérieurs bon pourquoi cette mesure est
juste parce que comme je vous le disais
il ya d'abord eu beaucoup d'opportunités
de substitut à ce qui devrait être
normalement dans une entreprise
l'augmentation des salaires deuxièmement
parce que ça a rendu plus facile
l'église heures supplémentaires dans les
grandes entreprises plutôt que la
création d'emplois et cela c'est aussi
les ouvriers c'est aussi des employés
quand vous êtes demandeur d'emploi vous
êtes aussi dans ces milieux-là 3 et donc
si on veut soutenir le pouvoir d'achat
et là on n'a pas de leçon à recevoir de
l'opposition ce n'est pas par ce
mécanisme là qu'on doit le faire bon la
troisième raison c'est quand même con et
avec un déficit financier très important
donc quand on veut combler le déficit
faut d'abord faire entrer les ressources
fiscales légitime
il n'est pas normal qu'une heure
travailler normalement ou quelqu un qu
une augmentation de salaire va payer des
impôts sur cette augmentation de salaire
et celui qui ferait une heure
supplémentaire ne paierait pas d'impôt
dessus c'est d'ailleurs ce principe
constitutionnel d'égalité de traitement
qui rendait difficile si même nous
l'avions souhaité d'avoir un traitement
différencié sur la fiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires entre les petites
et les grandes entreprises
voilà donc c'est une bonne mesure
maintenant elle ne peut pas à elle seule
résoudre les problèmes il faut
s'attaquer à l'amélioration du pouvoir
d'achat je pense par exemple aux heures
supplémentaires des enseignants qui
faisait des études et autres
c'est sûr qu'il va falloir discuter
quand même on ne peut pas dire aux
enseignants
il faut créer des postes mais ils ont
aussi pas si bien rémunérés que cela
donc pour réfléchir sur leur grille
salariale et
c'est un paquet qui doit être négocié
entre la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires qui est pas une bonne
méthode et la relance de tout cas au
moins dans un premier temps maintenant
plus gros effort fiscal marie noëlle
lienemann va être demandé aux français
en 2013 c'était un apéritif la 33
milliards de recettes à trouver tout en
fiscalité les 33 milliards c'est pour
milliards de déficit à combler moi
j'essaie de croissance ont maintenu si
on revenons un petit peu à l'europe
vous vous dites que finalement il ne
faut pas ça reviens tu peux c'est à dire
qu' il ne faut qu' on ne signe pas le
traité on ne respecte pas les
engagements alors je distingue le cheval
dans le débat sur l'europe je distingue
deux choses le court terme et le long et
moyen terme
quand on voit un traité européen comme
c'est le cas de ce qui nous arrive à
être nous est proposé on fait des choix
dans la longue durée qui traite le court
terme et le moyen long terme comprennent
bien très très très brièvement vous êtes
d'accord pour respecter les engagements
notamment de 3% sur les trois enfants je
suis je suis d'accord pour les respecte
et je pose la question du délai pour
l'atteindre
que ce soit un an près ou deux ans près
6 et pendant l'année si vous prenez un
an de plus pour atteindre l'objectif ou
deux ans de plus pour atteindre
l'objectif
et pendant ce temps là vous avez remis
en route le moteur de la croissance
c'est beaucoup mieux que d'atteindre
l'objectif en ayant complètement plombé
la croissance et les capacités de rebond
et là vous êtes quand même d'accord pour
évidemment par les dangers de la france
je suis une vraie qui ne pas faire
cavalier seul dans l'europe ça mais ce
n'est pas une question cavalier seul je
suis d'accord on a sign on respecte mais
ils auront du temps et surtout discuter
avec nos partenaires on n'est pas les
seuls avec devant ça depuis qu'on a
signé le traité d'amsterdam
il ya eu au moins cinq six sept ans où
la plupart des pays n'ont pas atteint
les objectifs
et c'est là où système vicié des
objectifs de co2 déficit publique et
d'endettement devrait être calé par
l'ensemble des pays de l'union où ceux
de la zone euro sur un des legs par
exemple audi pendant cinq ans ont fait
tomber nos déficits à des niveaux et on
investit avec de l'emprunt at any veau
et parce que du point de vue du cadre
économique dans lequel nous vivons
il ya des moments où il faut relancer et
de moments où il faut engranger les
fruits de la croissance pour réduire les
déficits et donc ça ça doit être des
choix politiques décidées par les des
représentants élus ça doit pas être
gravé dans le marbre une fois pour tous
et 0,3 ou bien la c3 et maintenant c'est
zéro c'est à dire qu'on tue toute
possibilité de ce que j'appelle une
politique keynésienne
c'était une épreuve qu'on appelle
contracyclique par rapport à l'économie
c'est à certains moments faut booster à
d'autres moments il faut rééquilibrer
on ne prend pas en compte la différence
entre une dépenses ordinaires de
fonctionnement et des défenses
d'investissement qui compte pour
l'avenir c'est pas la même chose de
donner une aide sociale parce que les
salaires sont trop bas que l'économie
nous fait plein de pauvres et cet argent
n'est pas très productif même s'il n
humainement nécessaire et puis
d'investir de l'éducation dans les
grandes infrastructures
donc il faut des choix politiques ce qui
ne veut pas dire des choix laxistes
on va passer à un autre sujet marie
noëlle lienemann c'est l'une des
annonces de l'intervention
présidentielle du 14 juillet la création
d'une commission sur la moralisation de
la vie politique
promesse de campagne de françois
hollande c'est à l'ancien premier
ministre lionel jospin reçu ce lundi à
l'elysée que revient la charge de
présider cette commission mais il ne
sera pas tout seul à exercer cette
lourde tâche 120 sert qu'à retirer de la
vie politique depuis dix ans mais très
actif dans la campagne présidentielle
lionel jospin revient aux
responsabilités il va présider la
commission sur la rénovation de la vie
publique
les sujets qui l'attendent sont nombreux
la recherche d'un meilleur déroulement
de l'élection présidentielle avec un
regard notamment sur le statut
juridictionnelle du chef de l'état une
réflexion sur la réforme des cibles des
modes de scrutin pour les élections
législatives et sénatoriales
et puis enfin le troisième grand champ
de réflexion s'engage entre dans les
détails va concerner des règles
déontologie permettant d'assurer une
meilleure transparence à la vie publique
une commission paritaire qui comporte
quatorze membres des universitaires des
hauts fonctionnaires mais aussi et c'est
une surprise
roselyne bachelot a par l'ancien
ministre ump et lionel jospin
aucun membre des tissus d'un
gouvernement ce que regrette la patronne
des sénateurs communistes qui dénonce un
manque de diversité politique
pour les écologistes la composition de
cette commission doit être modifié à
droite on s'interroge sur son utilité
c'est une commission jospin formé de
gens qui ne font plus de politique ils
n'ont jamais fait qui va dire comment
doivent être faites les élections
politiques on veut pas en parler au
parlement
ça sert à quoi le parlement la
commission jospin se réunira dès le 25
juillet un rapport doit être rendu début
novembre
alors c'est le grand retour de lionel
jospin qu'est ce que vous en pensez
écoutez je pense surtout que des sujets
comme cela c'est de la compétence du
parlement jeu aussi bah oui pour une
fois ne faut pas exagérer moi je pense
que revaloriser le parlement est une
question centrale dans notre démocratie
le rôle du parlement c'est de faire du
travail qui préparent des décisions
politiques de l'exécutif sur des grands
champs où il faut que c'est quand même
pas des experts qui vont décider de ce
que nous trouvons normal de faire dans
le mode de scrutin de faire dans mais
parce que c'est vrai aussi de votre
bouche et des deux
et de mon facteur c'est vrai de tous les
citoyens pourquoi des grands experts
vous croyez qu'ils n'ont pas une idée
sur la manière dont leurs problèmes
peuvent remonter à l'assemblée comment
le mode de scrutin permet d'être sûr que
tous les territoires du dernier des
petits villages jusqu'aux quartiers de
nos grandes villes puissent être
entendus vous croyez que les élus sont
moins compétents que ces expériences
variées ils peuvent parfois être enfin
ils le sont d'ailleurs partie prenante
est-ce qu'ils sont les mieux placés
finalement pour décider de leur sort je
pense au cumul des mandats dont on va
parler un petit peu plus tard pour
considérer qu'ils vont voter
de toute façon c'est eux qui vont voter
donc pour avoir un vote le plus en
avance possible il faut mettre ces le
parlement en situation d'assumer sa
responsabilité et de l'assumer
face au public moi je préférerais une
commission préparatoire avec l'ensemble
des représentants du parlement avec des
auditions publiques comme comme on le
fait d'ailleurs très souvent au sénat
avec des prises de positions chacun
assume ce qu'il est plutôt que d'essayer
de faire croire qu'on va trouver des
consensus qui de toute façon n'auront
pas lieu ou de croire qu'on va pouvoir
contourner les politiques dans leurs
votes
en revanche les politiques faut qu'ils
se sentent engagés et les commissions
doivent pas servir de prétexte
je crois qu'on en reparlera tout à
l'heure le cumul des mandats il n'y a
pas besoin de commission dire un seul
mandat
il n'y a pas besoin de 25000 travaux
c'est maintenant qu'il faut le faire
alors si c'est pas cette session ça doit
être impérativement à la suivante et
qu'on me fasse pas de voir que marie
noëlle lienemann donc c'est un peu la
commission de trop mais sur le fond il
ya quand même un besoin de localisation
doivent ils absolument tout à fait
fondamentale rénovation profonde et
parmi ces rénovations galles poilleux le
pouvoir du parlement parce que quand
vous n'avez pas une responsabilité
directe s'est jamais de la faute de
personne dans ce pays kantienne d'un
vote
quand on annonce est pas de ma faute
c'est bercy c'est ceci ou cela faut que
les politiques assument ce qu'ils votent
ce qu'ils font est donc oui et puis il y
à moraliser
il ya vérifier aussi que la diversité de
l'agd du cadre politique est bien
représenté la question de la
proportionnelle est une question
centrale qui peut pas être contourné en
même temps il faut trouver un système
qui se stabilise aux institutions parce
que bon par exemple de ce point de vue
soit l'exemple portugais sur l'exemple
allemand il ya de la proportionnelle et
en même temps c'est des régimes stables
donc il y a il ya moyen de vous disiez
parce qu'un début donc de votre réaction
sur cette commission il ya que des
experts il ya quand même roselyne
bachelot c'est une façon pratique
l'ouverture comme l'avait fait nicolas
sarkozy alors bah écoute et j'espère que
le gouvernement va pas pratiquer
l'ouverture parce qu'on a vu le succès
de cette affaire l'ouverture est un
mythe qu'on soit attentif à respecter
l'opposition est nécessaire moi je suis
pas d'accord très souvent avec
l'opposition
je pense qu'elle a une fonction
impérieuse utile en tout cas de
s'attacher à la voir même quand ça nous
déplaît bon donc le pouvais le droit de
l'opposition c'est très important mais
faire croire qu'ils ont brouille les
cartes qui en a qui ceci qu'on serait
ouvert parce qu'on va déboucher 3 non ça
chaque fois qu'un gouvernement ou qu'un
président a fait ça ça s'est retourné
contre lui et ça finit par le fait que
sa majorité perd des élections
même quand c'était nous là on va parler
- des cumuls du cumul des mandats et
mardi c'est le sénateur claude dilain
qui revient à la charge avec une
pétition contre le cumul des mandats
il est au menu de la nouvelle commission
jospin et provoque des remous au sénat à
claude dilain relance le débat avec une
pétition que vous avez signé marie
noëlle lienemann après son élection
c'est là le parlementaire socialiste
avait démissionné de sa mairie de clichy
sous bois sans brassard car il s'agit
bien d'une remise au point
l'appel lancé par claude dilain contre
le cumul des mandats visent à faire
taire ceux qui pensent que la promesse
de campagne aurait du plomb dans l aile
je ne fais rien d'autre que dire ce qu'a
dit le parti socialiste et qui a été
voté par les militants de dire ce qu'a
dit le président de la république est ce
qu a dit le premier ministre dans sa
déclaration de politique générale donc
je n'ai pas l'impression d'avoir fait
une révolution mais les réticences
persistent ils ne sont pour l'instant
qu'une vingtaine à avoir signé l'appel
si la loi passe un jour il ne sera plus
possible de cumuler mandats
parlementaire et exécutif local y
renoncer c'est pour certains élus ce
coupé des réalités du terrain et des
pays qui font de leur deuxième chambre
l'assemblée les territoires c'est le cas
de l'allemagne qu'on cite en exemple 25
par jour sur tous les sujets
et nous on est en train de faire le
contraire sûr que ce que dans l'air du
temps soit une bonne chose pour faire
face aux résistances une solution de
compromis serait à l'étude
pourquoi pas continuer à cumuler mais à
condition que ce soit à la tête d'une
petite ville s'agit-il de trouver
l'effet de seuil à partir de quel type
d'exécutif de quel type de démographie
il est souhaitable de faire ceci ou de
faire cela entre une commune de 3500
habitants et une grosse ville il faudra
trancher
c'est donc là dessus que devrait porter
le débat au risque de rogner sur la
réforme qui au départ portait sur le
mandat unique alors marie noëlle
lienemann on l'a dit on vous l'avait
signé cette pétition pourtant le sénat
constitutionnellement se veut le
représentant et le représentant des
territoires ce qu'on peut comprendre
quand même qu'il ya un besoin d'un
ancrage local pour les sénateurs et vous
n'avez pas besoin d'avoir en même temps
de mandat pour avoir un ancrage local
vous pouvez en avoir eu un vous pouvez
rester ancrée sur votre territoire sans
experts sans être présent conseil
général sans être tête d'un exécutif
avait été vous à une époque est député
et maire absolument géniale est même
compatible
c'est pas que c'est incompatible c'est
que j'ai observé aussi d'abord à
l'époque où j'étais il y avait moins de
décentralisation et à l'époque on était
moins directement la gestion mais je
plaide coupable
c'était éprouvant et c'est vrai qu'au
bout d'un moment on délègue beaucoup
alors moi j'ai toujours travaillé dans
ma mairie jeux sur travailler en équipe
ma première adjointe où mon premier
adjoint blanc deuxième mandat avait
beaucoup de responsabilités mais pour
être franche j'ai quand je compte que je
lui en ai juste pas souhaité que les
ministres cumulent pas j'ai quitté ma
mairie mon premier adjoint est devenue
mère et il est toujours maire et
franchement je n'ai pas de remords de
céder 6 il ya vous êtes simplement
sénatrice je suis en soit voilà
absolument et je suis pour un mandat
unique parce que à l'expérience j'ai vu
que ce n'est plus possible et alors
après c'est le directeur de cabinet
c'est le premier adjoint c'est le
secrétaire-général fin maintenant
directeur du service dans les mairies
qui finalement font l'arbitrage en lieu
et place du maire ou qui vient juste de
temps en temps et c'est tout moi je
pense que c'est
mais un de réticences de la part des
sénateurs la réforme a quasiment du
plomb dans l aile on l'a vu lors du
discours de jean marc ayrault ici de
nombreux sénateurs sont montés au
créneau en disant qu' on ne suivra pas
le gouvernement dans cette voie ils ne
voteront pas si vous voulez on va pas
non plus moi je peux mettre un flingue
au devant chacun de mes collègues mais
voyez vous voyez là c'est l'illustration
que les experts parfois sont mieux
placés pour stationner de paris les
parlementaires parce que je respecte
plus le collègue aura le courage de
voter contre d'assumer son vote
call expert qui va donner des leçons qui
n'est obligé que ça va arriver où ici
verts eelv ont voté contre
c'est pas forcément le bon choix c'est
en tout cas ce que bien évidemment mais
il m'arrive comme mes collègues vote
contre ce que je pense être le bon choix
je leur dis simplement les collègues il
faudrait que s'explique devant le peuple
et c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
de rallye dans ses couloirs et de lever
sa main pour dire non non j'en veux pas
du cumul des mandats donc justement moi
je préférais voyez plutôt qu'une
commission d'experts qu'on dise je me
suis dit là on le met à la tête d'ing
d'une commission de parlementaires pour
faire des propositions en vue d'une
proposition de loi au prochain pendant
le à l'automne alors on va continuer à
voir l'actualité ensemble mardi toujours
un discours attendu de françois hollande
sur le thème de la fin de vie le
président de la république est en
déplacement dans une maison médicale à
rueil malmaison dans les hauts de seine
il avait promis pendant sa campagne
d'envisager une révision de la loi
leonetti il propose de créer une mission
de réflexion sur la fin de vie en écoute
peut-on aller plus loin dans les cas
exceptionnels où l'abstention
thérapeutique ne suffit pas à soulager
des patients aux prises avec une douleur
irréversible et qu'ils appellent un acte
médical assumer un travail de réflexion
d'information de concertation sera donc
conduit et j'ai confié la mission de
mener ce travail au professeur didier
sicard ici présent président d'honneur
du comité consultatif national d'éthique
dont qu'on comprenne bien la loi
leonetti prévoit le laisser mourir il
s'agirait là d'aller plus loin avec un
mot à dire un geste actifs plus actif
dans certains cas très précis
france ô l'on ne prononce pas le mot
d'euthanasie c'est un sujet tellement
sensible que le mot ne peut être
prononcée vous voyez bien que dans
l'histoire l'euthanasie elle a quand
même eu des connotations extrêmement
redoutable
1 il s'agit pas d'une taille nazis au
sens de dire les gens sont pas utiles
vont terminer
bon il s'agit d'accompagner la personne
dans sa fin de vie par une maîtrise
autant que faire se peut de d'elle-même
de ses choix de la manière de le faire
avec toute la difficulté en fin de vie
selon les circonstances de pouvoir
exprimer son avis si je puis dire avec
liberté autonomie et conscience donc de
ce point de vue le sujet évidemment
complexe et pour le coup je pense qu'on
ne peut pas se prendre une décision
nouvelle sont deux conditions la
première à voir bien évaluer
l'effectivité de la mise en oeuvre de la
loi léonetti et de son efficacité ou de
ses limites parce que elle est quand
même que de 2005 il a l'air de rien ses
longs que les pratiques se mette en
oeuvre dans des domaines comme cela et
deuxièmement je pense qu'effectivement
faut aller plus loin parce qu'on a tous
vécu autour de nous des épisodes
familiaux douloureux où on a eu le
sentiment que la loi telle qu'elle était
ne répondait pas au bien être de fins de
vie des de nos proches donc je pense
qu'il va falloir la changer cette loi
l'améliorer si je puis dire lui ouvrir
des champs nouveaux
je pense que peut-être précautions
nécessaires avec toutes les précautions
et ne pas confondre les mots
l'euthanasie c'est quand vous dites je
vais ou tanaz et c'est c'est vous même
qui décide et pour l'autre là c'est pas
du tout l'euthanasie il y en a aucune
une commission qui est qui est créé sur
ce thème là bien particulier mais de
façon générale ça fait déjà deux
commissions en mission de réflexion en
deux jours plus toutes celles qui ont
été annoncées os concret trop de ça fait
beaucoup
ça fait un peu rentré un dossier
alors c'est pour ça qu'il faut quand
même à mon avis bien distinguer les
enjeux ce qui était clairement affirmée
et qui peut être mis en oeuvre
rapidement parce que l'engagement était
clair et la mise en oeuvre n'est pas
d'une complexité folle voilà donc ça par
exemple le cumul des mandats moi je peux
entendre les 3500 habitants
bon faut quand même aller au coeur de
cible donc il faut un parlement qui
puisse rapidement décidé il ya des cas
où il faut négocier que les partenaires
sociaux je pense par exemple tout ce qui
était sur le grand sommet social par
exemple les licenciements économiques
bon ben il faut un peu négocier parce
que c'est sûr qu'on peut pas bon mais il
faut peut-être butoir et dans la
commission tout 20 d'émissions mais pas
trop et bien souvent des vagues les bien
ciblées et des dates butoirs toutefois
pas giuly premiers pas marie noëlle
lienemann vers le congrès du parti
socialiste qui se tiendra à toulouse fin
octobre avec la présentation des
contributions route vers le congrès au
parti socialiste c'est la journée des
contributions avant l'émotion qui
détermine les rapports de force
alors il ya celle de martine aubry et de
jean marc ayrault qui entend rassembler
les socialistes
mais benoît hamon se veut le grain de
sel le grain de sable du conseil
national le ministre délégué à
l'économie solidaire et chef de file de
l'ailé gauche du parti compte bien faire
entendre sa voix jean baptiste daoulas à
l'entrée du conseil national benoît
hamon fait figure de mauvais élève du
gouvernement il est le seul ministre à
avoir signé une contribution différente
de celle de martine aubry et jean-marc
ayrault
d'abord il n'y a pas de consignes faut
arrêter
le premier ministre il donne pas de
consignes c'est pas son tempérament il
est chef du gouvernement d'un chef du
gouvernement il ya chef bien sûr mais de
l'action du gouvernement après y'a le
parti a le groupe etc
mais le chef de la majorité se chargent
de siffler la fin de la récréation une
discussion avec lui
il est membre du gouvernement je
souhaite qu'au moment où on soumettra au
vote des militants un texte une motion
nous soyons tous rassemblés pour
inscrire dans la durée le travail que la
gauche veut faire au service du pays
en clair signé une contribution
différente passe encore mais pas
question de soutenir une motion
différente lors du congrès l'autre
grande inconnue c'est l'avenir de
martine aubry
des rumeurs ne cessent d'annoncer son
retrait ou un nouveau bail à la tête du
ps essayez d'éviter d'écrire des papiers
tous les jours en expliquant ce sont mes
états d'âme c'est moi même qui ai dit
que je souhaitais quitter le parti
socialiste
dès que les conditions étaient réunies
je crois qu'un grand pas est fait
aujourd'hui le sort de martine aubry
sera connue au plus tard le 12 septembre
c'est à cette date que l'émotion seront
déposées la motion aubry héros devrait
bénéficier d'une majorité écrasante
leur contribution a réuni aujourd'hui 88
% des parlementaires et 75% des
secrétaires fédéraux du parti le ps a
aussi renouvelé ses cadres en nommant
des jeunes et des femmes au secrétariat
national
vous avez salué la motion la
contribution 1 2 benoît hamon est-ce
qu'on peut être au gouvernement et
défendent une contribution émotion
différente de celle du premier
istres jour fait ça s'est toujours fait
jean pierre chevènement quant au
président mitterrand était président de
la république au congrès de prendre et
c'est à déposer des motions qui ont
recueilli 15 d'intentions dans le parti
et jean pierre chevènement quand il a
quitté le ps s'était bien après ça
n'avait rien à voir
jean luc mélenchon reveillez vous dans
ce gouvernement c'est finalement tous
les miss se sont ralliés alors qu'ils
avaient chacun des impressions je
gagnais je pense qu'il ya une amicale
pression comme on dit dans avec les
formules diplomatiques habituels une
amicale pression qui les a amenés à être
dans l'obligation de signer cet oubli
pas qu'ils étaient en désaccord mais la
pression on dit qu'il ya des consignes
avaient envoyé enfin la question et les
mois de la consigne c'est un climat
quand on vous dit on a écouté la jean
marc ayrault pour qui j'ai un grand
respect que je trouve un bon premier
ministre
mais enfin on va pas faire un congrès du
ps pour contre le gouvernement moi je
déposerai probablement une notion avec
mes amis et d'autres parce que nous
avons des désaccords sur certains sujets
ou en tout cas nous voulons infléchir un
certain nombre de décisions qui
n'étaient pas dans les 60 engagement de
de françois hollande qui nous engage
tous un
quand on est dans une situation où on
doit avoir un débat c'est évidemment pas
les pour et les contre le gouvernement
enfin où l'on vit et la crise ne
justifie pas l'unité
c'est un petit ballon c'est le même
débat sur l'unité nationale y aurait une
crise dont au contraire la grande
question c'est quelle est la sortie de
crise il est là il doit y avoir débat il
ya des gens qui vous disent n ya pas de
problème la crise des telles que ça va
remettre en cause le système j'observe
que paradis fiscaux produits dérivés des
laudes et des régulations bancaires
écrasement de l'économie réelle par
rapport à l'économie financière tout ça
continue comme un rouleau compresseur
alors qu'on aurait pu penser que la
crise allait amener à notre politique
j'observe une autre chose c'est quand il
ya une alternative que chercher à les
chercher vers l'intégrisme extrême
droite où les pensée totalitaire jeudi
si la gorge à marmande bout on n'a pas
signé de contribuer ce oui mais arnaud
bon et à renouer aussi au front
deux sujets majeurs 1 qui compte qui
correspondent aux sujets qu'il a posé
bon moi je respecte chacun juste en
train de donner des de faire des bons
points et de morale jeudi par contre le
droit du militant et le devoir du
militant du cadre politique de dire ce
qu'il a à dire dans le respect des
règles de notre parti et de l'efficacité
du gouvernement
c'est un impérieux devoir en début de
quinquennat sinon on aura des retours de
bâton
difficile alors voilà d'arnaud
montebourg parle donc peut-être un mot
sur martine aubry vous pensez qu'elle
doit ou qu'elle va se représenter comme
hier c'était moi je fais comme elle
j'écoute ce qu'elle dit je crois ce
qu'elle dit voilà qu'est ce que l'on va
pas commencer à être d un jeudi blanc je
fais noir et ben non elle a dit qu'elle
va faire ouais elle dit quoi le dis plus
rien ne dit pas qu'elle soit rappelée
laquelle avait pris des engagements que
ces conditions elle est en train de
revenir ça c'est très c'est très
subjectif
bien sûr mais elle est en train de vous
dire la réunion là que tout à l'heure
que elle pensait que ça allait dans le
bon sens donc moi je fais comme elle je
constate de toute façon les premiers le
premier secrétaire ne sera plus élu par
un vote alternative au suffrage
universel puisque c'est obligatoirement
la tête de liste de la motion des deux
motions majoritaire qui peuvent se
présenter
les deux motions en tête pardon qui
peuvent se présenter et donc de fait ce
sera celui qui aurait fait cooptés dans
la motion majoritaire
arnaud montebourg donc on en parle a
poursuivi cette semaine ses
consultations avec les acteurs du drame
social de psa peugeot-citroën rencontre
avec les syndicats de l'entreprise puis
mercredi avec le président philippe
varin qui avait déclaré auparavant
n'avoir pas d'autre choix que de fermer
le site d'aulnay supprimer 8000 emplois
ce même mercredi n'était entendu à
l'assemblée l'ancien pdg de renault
louis schweitzer
pourquoi la marque au losange se
porte-t-elle mu aujourd'hui que son
concurrent français peugeot réponse
fermeture d'aulnay et est
incontournable pour psa mais au fond
quelle est la différence on dire non on
va un peu mieux que ps en ce moment au
fond quelle est la différence mais que
renault a pris le contrôle de nissan que
renault a fait dacia est que renault a
géré le camion avec volvo donc au fond
c'est en allant à l'étranger qu'on s'est
évité un certain nombre de problèmes en
france
voilà la solution c'est de produire à
l'étranger
j'ai beaucoup d'amitié pour lui ce fait
de serre je pense quand même qu'il faut
un peu nuancé parce que je ne veux pas
défendre peugeot je pense que j'ai lu
l'interview de monsieur peugeot dans le
figaro je pense quand même que il a tort
de monter le ton comme cela et j'espère
que les esprits vont se pacifier parce
que quand même quand on a un pdg d'une
entreprise qui vous explique que non non
non la feuille qui a sorti la cgt c'est
pas vrai c'est faux il y aura jamais ça
et que c'est exactement ça qui se
déroule bon on peut appeler ça avec les
mots pudiques qu'on veut c'est quand
même un mensonge bon et c'est n'est pas
sain pour la négociation sociale et le
dialogue dans notre pays mais néanmoins
n'accablons pas que peugeot peugeot a
moins fait partir hors de france oui
mais aujourd'hui non mais justement une
partie de sa production et faire croire
que l'issue peugeot ce serait de faire
comme renault je ne suis pas d'accord
avec cela
qu'il y ait des alliances stratégiques
avec d'autres à l'étranger pour exporter
oui externalisés à l'extrême les la sous
traitance en dehors du pays
non maintenant c'est doit être un devoir
et je rappelle que l'état est
actionnaire de renault sur la prom' de
coût du travail
arrêtez de dire il ya un problème de
coût du travail attendez en temps réel
mais elle est partielle avec l'allemagne
bon donc en allemagne de coûts du
travail dans l'automobile est supérieur
au coût du travail en france donc
et que ce soit sous traitance ou
production donc la réalité c'est aussi
que l'allemagne a fait des choix de
gamme qui correspondait au fait où le
coût du travail sur les gammes élevé à
moins d'impact sur les gammes petit je
ne dis pas qu'il ya pas de questions
avoir sur le calcul
notamment des cotisations sociales
depuis des années ceux déjà sous jospin
et déjà son idée ranger disait le calcul
des cotisations de social doit être fait
sur la valeur ajoutée dans l'entreprise
et pas sur la masse salariale
et pourquoi même pas d'avoir une vision
un peu différente de ce calcul selon les
secteurs très exposée à l'exportation ou
où les secteurs qui ne sont pas quand
vous pensez que l'essentiel de nos
allégements de cotisations touche auchan
carrefour
franchement c'est pas pour ça qu'ils
vont être une pierre une caissière de
plus il perd quand même des boulons et
il bénéficie d' davantage donc je dis il
ya un vrai sujet de repenser les grandes
filières industrielles de spi avec les
acteurs qui sont maîtres n'a de l'argent
public dans certains jeux quand j'arrive
l'état est actionnaire
m les moyens aussi mais pousse tel cas
pour nous et je veux absolument que les
entreprises et et j'invite à ce que nos
amis puissent lire le blog de madame
karine berger économiste désormais
député les modes de calcul de
rentabilité dans l'industrie aujourd'hui
c'est ça doit être rentable en un an
on sait qu'il faut c'est en six ans du
cycle il faut organiser pour que
l'investissement long terme et la
rentabilité à long terme soit revalorisé
par rapport au court terme alors
repasser au jeudi très vite quand un
député réclame plus de transparence dans
les comptes des députés
et en ce jeudi c'est le député centriste
charles de courson qui persiste et signe
il va déposer un amendement pourtant
rejeté en commission ils demandent que
soient fiscalisés et surtout contrôler
les frais de mandat des parlementaires
de quoi s'agit-il valérie brochard
soizic bonvarlet en ce début de 14e
législature et de majorités socialistes
les députés s'apprêterait-il a voté
l'abolition des privilèges
apparemment pas puisque le 11 juillet
dernier la commission des finances a
rejeté massivement l'amendement du
député udf charles de courson visant à
fiscaliser l'indemnité représentative
des fragments da salle des quatre
colonnes
les députés n'ont pas franchement envie
d'évoquer le sujet j'ai même pas d'idée
sur rien du tout ni télé représentative
de frais de mandat n'est pas le problème
c'était une proposition d'un moment en
commission des finances il a été rejeté
monsieur livre l'indemnité d'un montant
de 6000 412 euros mensuels doit
permettre aux députés de faire face aux
dépenses liées à l'exercice de leur
mandat non prises en charge par
l'assemblée distingue de l'indemnité
parlementaire principal salaires
proprement dits des députés et en
complément du crédit pour l'emploi des
collaborateurs
li rfm doit permettre la prise en charge
du loyer de la permanence parlementaire
et des frais liés aux déplacements ou
cérémonies officielles
problème une partie de l'indemnité étant
souvent inutilisés et sans contrôle
existants hier fm peut être détournée à
des fins personnelles
récemment mediapart accusé le député
socialiste pascal terrasse de s'être
offert des vacances avec son nid rfm et
le mélange à la fois de ce qui relève de
mes indemnités d'élus dont je peux faire
ce que je veux de mon ire et pme je
pense que médiapart s'est un peu trompé
sur le fond de l'affairé des suspicions
que charles de courson voudrait faire
taire en soumettant à l'impôt sur le
revenu la partie de l'irfm non consommés
impliquant un contrôle par
l'administration fiscale des dépenses
des parlementaires
visiblement c'est un sujet sensible à
voir la réaction à des députés
interrogés dans ce reportage
est ce que c'est il faut qu est ce que
vous vous l'auriez voté l'amendement de
charles de courson
je pense que la bonne méthode c'est le
contrôle par les assemblées elles mêmes
par un collège de père de l'usaj de ces
fonds sur lequel les sénateurs comme les
députés les sommes qui sont donnés me
paraissent enfin il faut bien les
nuancer son brut 1 c'est pas vrai que
tous les moyens à 7600 euros qui tant
chez le grand que soi comme contrôle est
justifiée aux injustices absolument que
jusqu'à éventuellement mot verser
lorsqu'elles ne sont pas utilisés
interdit éventuellement renverser quand
elles sont pas utiliser intégralement
alors en prenant un laps de temps de
deux trois ans parce que j'avoue une
année vous allez rénover le siège
votre local cette année là vous dépensez
plus vous changez votre ordinateur
encore qu'on a du coup ça normal mais en
même temps l'amendement a été rejeté
ça suppose que c'est bercy qui va venir
voir comment les députés et vont
commencer à dire oui mais pourquoi vous
avez fait ça est ce que c'était bien
votre mandat et vous commencez à la
comment dire codifié ce qui procède de
la manière d'exercer son mandat ce qui
ne me paraît pas sain dans une
démocratie
au passage merci ne peut pas contrôler
les comptes des parlementaires sas au
nom de la séparation mais comptera ainsi
les aroud les impôts sur le revenu
contrôle des impôts sur le revenu mais
l'irs fn doit être contrôlée par les
l'assemblée par un collège de père voir
qu'ils puissent avoir quelques grands
sages prônent est aussi l'instant il
faudrait merci beaucoup c'est la fin de
cette émission c'est la dernière de
l'année
on se retrouve donc en ce moment il dit
bon ça on remercie évidemment toutes les
équipes qui nous ont aidés à faire cette
émission cette année à commencer par
eléonore picot est évidemment toutes les
équipes en régie merci beaucoup mieux de
revoir et merci à vous devez ainsi